who i am is not so important let's talk
about the data right that's the thing
where it always starts
i was really happy that this was
possible again right after so long covet
and restrictions
one thing i missed was these little
talks at the coffee machine hey what are
you working on hey i used this package
hey blah blah blah and i
i had a little hunger for that so i
thought maybe i can recreate maybe your
appetite a little bit for those little
things so
let's keep it simple
uh data exploration and some packages
that can help you
and
before i start talking about data
exploration indeed where it all starts
the maybe the basics
let's first talk about the opposite of
data exploration because here i'm a
little bit uh
article guilty of this
more than once i maybe went too quick on
the data exploration phase and went like
a
a maniac focusing on the accuracy or on
the
f1 score or what have you and i i
actually
from that moment on completely ignored
the data and only when trying to improve
the score with tricks and
feature engineering so oh you need to
some books tell you at the later chapter
grid search is the next thing to do uh
hyper parameters okay okay let's let's
let's the computer
uh calculate and
that's uh part of the guilt is i think
of for me being not focused on the data
anymore but i also find that a lot of
books imply a little bit this kind of
order right so
maybe i should go to the library and put
a little a4 paper and now export the
data between every chapter that
hopefully people won't make this mistake
again yeah so this is uh
the opposite of
data exploration like a maniac only
focus on one thing and
try to improve it
so then i thought what is then data
exploration let's take this time to see
again
what is it
so i did the most popular phd nowadays
it's a youtube phd i will tell you how
it is you go to youtube you find your
topic and you search and you come into a
funnel and then you research research
research research
this is one of the videos
i
found it is
leo braeman
he is more or less or at least made it
famous the guy from the random forest
the guy of the decision trees
and also he get credit for
inventing the ideas of the
booster the xg boost boosters with a
loss function so he i think he's a hero
i'm a fan of leo brymon
it's a fantastic video there's not many
videos of leo breiman so it's really
easy to find it on youtube leo brymon
and then the one or two videos
only the first five seconds is already
interesting because there leo breiman
says something like
lord it's difficult to stay humble so he
was really sure of what he had to say so
and then he's talking about his work
he's been in academics uh for university
then he went in consultancy and a little
bit uh an all-rounder
with data well the inventor of the
random forest so he has earned a stripe
right
and uh
somewhere in the video he he's really um
on the table it's so important to get to
know your data he's it's that's what i
learned in consultancy you got to know
your data so that was this number one
rule so that's uh well that's another
vote for data exploration is important
leo bryman didn't import python packages
he did something else
in this case where he talks about he had
a really interesting way of data
exploration
i see some friends here so you are not
allowed to talk but can anybody guess or
maybe remember what was leo breiman's
way of data exploration
anybody want to make a guess
what excel excel
very close you said basic even more
basic he printed everything the data on
paper sheets and he put his whole office
full with the data and he said people
can buy my office and they laugh so data
exploration literally get a relation
with the data print all the data and put
this whole office full with the data
then he went thinking
about it from how can i uh what what is
special about this one how is it
different
really let's say data exploration in his
head
and
what i liked is
this was his idea as a first step for
a decision tree for a random forest
so and i think that's my next slide yes
what i did is the right one i got my
data a little bit data exploration bomb
i put it in the render for us let's see
what happens right that's a little bit
uh what well
my what i'm guilty of not doing enough
so
the
maybe the first decision tree first
random forest was actually
different
start a relation with your data so that
was uh printing the whole data on your
office and get a relation get to know it
and then create features and then he put
it in the model so that is a whole
different way of
data exploration and
i when i rewatched it i thought hey
that's that's uh
that's a different way than most people
use a random forest right you put your
data in it and that's it but the first
one was actually created with a lot of
data exploration literally printing the
data on the wall learn from it create
features and then he thought a
tree based model is a good idea
all right so
before we start at take a look at data
exploration what are typical things i
think it's a little bit a
creative process right every data set is
different so i feel a little bit should
i give a list of what well that but if
you if you uh
read the books if you read the blogs and
these are typical things that you can
find
um
interactions and correlations
note the correlation matrix that you
often see is actually a way to say
how linear related are these two
variables that's just a linear relation
also got me thinking why we have so much
compute power so much techniques we
still use a
little matrix that only tells the linear
relation there's so much more relation
you can do but that's a little bit uh
culture legacy what we're used to let's
see how linear related they are
in the example that i later will show we
will actually see that this causes a no
not necessarily a problem but that if
it's if there's an interaction but not
necessarily linear then
just looking at the correlation matrix
might give you not all the information
problems there's of course always
problems in the data missing values
outliers or suburbs i call them this is
not a textbook language but maybe
there's a subset in the data that should
need special care
etc etc
another thing
after you made your first model and and
i i always advise to keep it simple your
first model let's keep it simple easy
straightforward model
it makes some errors it's also of course
interesting to
explore with data actually what kind of
error is my naive optimistic model
making that's another way that's really
good
and another one is
maybe your model doesn't necessarily
make an error but
where is it not where is it not so sure
what are the weak points of your model
and often the difference between a
better model and a alright model is
those data points that are a little bit
tricky a little bit difficult so this
gives
maybe good ideas for
feature engineering
and uh this is uh
a cup of coffee but maybe this is the
number one feature engineering tool
because with a cup of coffee you can
walk to the experts and
discuss hey what's what's this process
behind it and a cup of coffee is my
number one feature engineering tool but
maybe the second one is data exploration
because from data exploration it's
another great input of feature
engineering
one thing i noticed is that on kaggle
you cannot have a coffee with the expert
because on in competitive data science
bomb you get the data set and that's it
you can only do data exploration but in
real life it's much more
effective to have a coffee but then the
data exploration is maybe is a second
good source of feature engineering
and then the third one and
here it starts a little bit do you
believe in it or not but trial and error
you can throw a computer at it some
automatic machine learning claim they
can do feature engineering automatically
for you if you believe that you can do
automated machine learning but still
data exploration is a good way to do
feature engineering
so
i was there looking at my f score and
then suddenly you see oh my god i
completely forgot a interaction in my
data right and this is exactly the
feeling that i had a few times i thought
oh what was i doing i completely forgot
that there was this or that yeah this
this is uh how i felt some credit to the
photographer because i i was searching
for a picture like this i thought yeah
this this is it he actually knew what
was going on but he lives there for so
many months he have seen it it's just as
normal for him as we see some birds
flying so he didn't bother about it but
it's it's of course the joke is that
he's so obsessed with something that he
completely ignores the fact what's
happening behind him
and that's a little bit of danger
cool i promise you a interactive demo
etc etc etc we have 90 minutes left so i
thought yeah this is too ambitious to do
it interactive
are you all right if it's just some
slides about the packages please say yes
otherwise
thank you thank you
so what i did is
took a standard data set the
california housing data set here's a
little bit the
uh the things that are in it it's a
standard sklearn data set and i made a
list of what i thought could help
everybody with data exploration and
these are
five packages that are
suitable for data exploration maybe you
know something maybe don't it's not
necessarily advised but it's fun to play
with it also a warning they're not
always so suitable for every situation
but let's go let's check the five
packages that hopefully can make your
life easier to do data exploration
this is a little bit the
less in the title let's do
less data exploration it's not a advice
to ignore data exploration but maybe you
can save time if the package can do the
work that you can do
i also will try to give every package a
compliment right what i like about it
but sometimes there's also things that i
wish that were improved
number one
pandas profiling i think almost
everybody knows it right yeah pandas pro
is is really really well
it's made by a dutch guy simon
before it was belgium so it's really
close to our home it's
belgium right eindhoven pretty close so
this is a
nice that it's from homemade or almost
and it also is
evolved a lot it can do text it can find
keywords in text it can find
interactions now it's pretty pretty well
made also uh
i like how it's installing better first
it was a pretty large dependency tree
going fighting with the current uh
numpy so i really like this package
there is something that you can already
see
just from this screenshot
here is the
age of the house or the average age and
what i noticed just by scrolling is it
seemed to be clipped so the data is
after 50 they say okay 50 and older so
let's say we didn't read we were not
able to read where the data come from
you see it's clipped so 50 actually
means 50 years and older because clearly
this this should be the till of all the
very old houses but it's just all
clipped to 50 so maybe an mp clipped or
something happened there
another thing
may be nice because but this also be on
the next slide i talked about that the
linear relation is not necessarily a
interaction
and there the house age and the
target the price of the house is very
very weak in linear relation so if we
just focus on this
correlation matrix you see oh that's
that's that's almost nothing that's as
good as random
so pandas profiling this is oh yeah the
best the best all rounder if you can
only pick one probably this is your pick
it's the best all-rounder
where i think it could be a little bit
improved is in the interactions because
there's a
interaction between each feature let's
say the target and the house age there
you there's a little plot
but there's more packages that can do
that one better so let's go to the next
sweet fizz
this is clearly the best in design
because wow it almost doesn't look like
it looks right with a nice shadow and
gradients and etc etc
it outputs to a pdf so you
when i use this i had to
run it output output oh sorry not pdf
html
that's not always uh
what you want right maybe you want to be
out like a picture and it's not that
that interactive it's more or less
you click all the all the uh
features of your data set
you can tell this is my target and
here you see the the same average house
age see here's the 50
and look the target which is the price
what happens
here what i guess would maybe slowly go
up as the age increases because usually
the old house is beautiful nice windows
and you expect that
the price goes up but actually point it
it's uh
since this still this should slowly not
only the data is clipped the target is
clipped too so that's where we see
already a problem in the data
yeah funny though so indeed the
correlation is not the same as
interaction
because if you want to
try to uh
a straight line that's not possible
that's why the
the uh
0.1 the the correlation the r or r
square i forgot exactly which one of
this is pretty low but clearly there's
some interaction
so sweet fizz is the most beautiful one
but it's not
in features it's a little bit low
but to get an idea of how the target is
related to your columns it's pretty good
because i like this simple plots
devil
that one is less well known
but i really like it but unfortunately
it's not so actively developed anymore
one thing why i like it is i see a
little bit older people here do you
remember the microsoft clippy the
interactive assistant tool that tells
you it looks like you're writing this in
this letter maybe you should
it reminds me a little bit of this first
ai interactive tool
because as soon and it's very easy to
use you see double dot plots and then
your data frame and then you give your
target column
i felt clippy was talking to me again it
looks like you're doing regression it
looks like you're doing classification
and then it will plot all this
beautiful pictures of how for instance
categorical uh
features are related to to a regression
to a uh
how to say to the target variable if
it's uh regression
this is actually not the data that i use
because when i did the
california housing data it was pretty
boring plots pretty boring scatter plots
so i cheated here by taking a screenshot
of the actual documentation but if you
want to see how it is on the california
data set you can later take a look at my
github
but it is really really well in
this kind of picture takes some time
some time and it's doing everything
automatically for you
where i think it could be improved is a
little bit less automatic it picks for
instance the 10 best interactions and i
sometimes want to see also the 11 and 12
and others and it's it's not that much
possible to customize devil but still
for getting a feeling of how your target
is related to the columns in your data
it's a fantastic tool and a real time
saver
day three this
another package for data exploration
slash creating a model
i had the most headache with this one
because you need to install
graph
what how is it called graph z graph is c
maybe you have a fight with this package
because uh if you
like keras and you want to plot
a
picture of the architecture of your
network usually it complains it cannot
find this little graphics but yeah you
see some people nodding that's the same
that this package needs so i was
spending a good uh
50 minutes half an hour to get the
dependencies working i thought oh my god
here we go again my old friend graff is
see that i need to install and roll
but i finally managed to do it
this is maybe the most creative one of
all the data exploration tools because
look what it does it makes a tree but
then for every tree you it plots the
with a scatter plot the data that is
affected by this little branch
really creative idea
i must be honest i own i never used it
in the weld on a real project but i
thought yeah let's mention this one it's
a it's a funny idea that and it might
might
give somebody at some point insights so
what you see here is for instance it did
a split on
medium income and then here
it decided if it's less than 5.04
and then exactly we can see that part of
the data on the left and if it splits on
something else average rooms or
average occupation it makes another
split so you
you get you get an idea how your uh
how subset of the data that this tree
algorithm thinks is is a good split to
make how it's uh
interacted with each other
and then
a completely different category
this is
interactive data exploration
here i must give a compliment to the
commercial tools there's a lot of
commercial
data science data exploration tools that
i think is far ahead of the open source
tools to do interactive data exploration
what are a few there's uh trifacta for
instance there is spss there's uh like
alt alteric all kind of those those
commercial tools to do a data
analysis data exploration
most most of the time they they're ahead
of the
open source
but i could find some open source and
that is detail
detail
and here it's
for for uh
well given the lack that the open source
is at this point i thought it was pretty
good to do interactive data exploration
i didn't read the documentation of
course not so i just installed it and
tried i think i should be able to use it
uh
pretty pretty
fast i was able to do a little uh uh
filtering on one of the
features and then go to plot my
filtering
i did on house house age smaller than 45
because i thought yeah because 50 is a
special case let's focus just on the 45
and then when i went to plot it was
keeping my filter active and i was able
to do all kinds of plots so this was the
one of the better open source
interactive data exploration tools i
could find
not that well known i don't hear it a
lot
it has some background with oh i should
stand on the cross it has some
background with sas so this is the
interactive data exploration tool
warning
it will expose itself as a website
and which port did i need to open and
then i start forty thousand as a what
forty thousand this is a high port to
open but you need to expose port forty
000
then detail will express itself as a
website and there i think it's a react
something website you can do interactive
data exploration
pretty pretty high port i remember it
from
spyware malware etc but 40 000 is what
detail needs to give you a nice web
interface to talk with the data
so these are the five
packages
what i hope
that everybody
will realize is that
almost in every point where you do your
data exploration making a model
improving your model i think at every
point we have the choice to either go
for a grid search or something else
right it's sometimes indeed it helps
but everybody always has the right to go
back to data exploration
so
even after your first model go back to
data exploration see the errors it's uh
there's there's a lot of i learned so by
doing this way
also this is the way i tell myself
the other way around
i need to create my first model and data
exploration as a right to try the more
complicated models
so
i see for instance xgboost as a little
bit more complicated model so i'm not
allowed maybe to use it i'm not i'm not
that strict for myself by the way but
let's let's call it to make it a little
bit more blunt i'm not allowed to use
xgboost the first way first i need to
earn my rights to do a little bit data
exploration see where the simple model
make their errors etc
before i forgot
i wanted to tell this in the beginning
but it can also be at the end
in the news now there's a lot of fuss
about andrew ing's new company and maybe
you've seen it in the blogs in your
twitter feed andrew ing had a new idea
and poof he had
i think 56 million for his startup so
andrew ing had another idea he's uh
maybe most famous for his machine
learning course on coursera that i think
everybody
likes loved or maybe did he's also
famous for his second thing he did deep
deeplearning.ai
and if you want to know more about deep
learning architectures etc etc you can
do his
so what was his latest tech startup
it's going back to the data his newest
idea of improving your model is going
back to the data and improve the labels
improve the quality
and that is his latest startup so i
thought that's fun to note
timing couldn't be better for me another
vote for data exploration is important
so yeah that's with that i would like to
end my talk and
hopefully get you some ideas to do data
exploration
awesome
thank you so much are there any
questions you can raise your hand okay
i'll bring the mic to you
hi uh do you have any uh suggestions for
how to deal with large data sets this
works for smaller data sets other than
just taking some random sample maybe
yeah i was a little bit afraid of that
question um
that's a really good point because
this is all cute and nice and then the
real deal right then you have a serious
data set
that was a little bit my uh note in the
beginning of uh they're not all that
suitable for real work
i guess these are almost not all
suitable for uh real work and i guess
that if the data gets bigger and bigger
and bigger usually your options get
smaller and smaller and smaller
i haven't
tested them
when i scale data up since
not sure but i i'm not sure about pandas
profiling but i didn't see any scalable
backend for any of them i think it's all
yeah
put it all in the memory and i will take
care of it and that's actually your
question yeah but that's not always
possible yeah completely agree so
maybe to get a little idea of your
sample and then unfortunately i have to
tell you and now you need to do it in
your parallel
platform yeah but good point yeah
any other questions
thank you
um do you have any suggestions for uh
something like exploration tracking in
the grid search of experiment tracking
and that works very well when you have
like a clear
structure in which you you are trying to
see all the options but when you're
doing eda it feels a lot more like oh
i've noticed this little thing i noticed
this little thing unless this little
thing and it doesn't fit in a very
nice structure of experiment tracking
you can log this but in the next
experiment you see something else
so
then the
first
idea is it can be structured right then
we have to first agree that data
exploration can be structured that there
is a structured way to do it
i'm not so sure if that's possible
because
sometimes
like maybe on kaggle where the data set
is fixed the problem is fixed the goal
is fixed in reality maybe the data is
not so fixed you find something out you
go back and it gets a little bit all
right and
and
i don't know about your experience with
experiment tracker i'm uh
don't ask me about my past experiments
because i didn't do them i know that
there exist tools like ammo flow but
i i haven't always tracked them down
my experience tracking is usually with a
sheet of paper and a pencil and then i
know and it's throws away
so if it can be i don't know this is
this is an interesting question because
uh but if it can be structured maybe
there can be a tool but i'm i'm a little
bit thinking about
the
structure that could be projected on
data exploration because maybe it is a
creative process and and shouldn't be
captured anyway because if it if it
could be then a little bit of the
creativity goes away is it that a little
bit uh yeah that's maybe
yeah yeah that's probably my answer yeah
i'll take one quick question and then we
go on a break because we're already
running a little behind so sorry is
there any more questions
yeah
thanks for talking uh just wondering do
you think it should be a separate role
in a team
uh for once doing exploration and oh the
data explorer
yeah well um one thing is for sure i
think the blog writers would love this
because uh there's every few months
there's another they're we're missing
the important role the data explorer
so for marketing per purpose i say yes
that's good then we have more work more
uh roles to fit
in in reality i i really feel it's uh
so
important for the one that created model
the wonder prepared data so maybe the
ideal world is
everybody in the same room and explore
the data and have a laugh and see what
you do
a little bit more creative so so again
by the structure
the the creativity the idea sharing goes
a little bit away by by giving somebody
an isolated role
but for the blocks it's a good idea so
still a good idea for for the marketing
yeah
you